to do it yes I would like to say
something go ahead
um I'm innocent you all your garbage
all right if you aren't aware Eli Hart
uh is a six-year-old boy who was in the
middle of a complicated custody battle
and in the process of the dad trying to
get full custody the child was returned
to his mom ten days later the kid was
sick well court documents show thaler
had only recently gotten her son back
for more than a year Dakota County
Social Services had custody of Eli but
despite even their concerns including
about thaler's mental health he was
returned to her Jennifer Hoff is digging
into how exactly that happened Juliet
May boil down to two things here
officials reported that they didn't have
concerns for Eli's physical well-being
while in his mother's care and his
father had recently filed for custody
but in order for that to move forward
experts tell us the County case to
protect that little boy had to be closed
first hulissa thaler is charged with
killing her son Eli Hart last week but
documents show she'd been filing abuse
reports against Eli's father Tori since
2016 when she was pregnant he's never
been criminally charged and thaler at
one point admitted her mental health
issues caused her to accuse accuse heart
of things that he doesn't do I can't
even tell you how many times you express
our concerns our fears heart's fiance
says he recently filed for custody of
Eli that was a little over a year after
court records showed Dakota County took
the boy into custody documents also show
thaler was hospitalized then and was
hearing voices telling her to keep
herself while Eli was in foster care
social workers continued to document red
flags about Baylor including that she
stopped seeing her therapist had
unstable housing and was charged for
stealing drugs despite that social
services and a court Guardian recently
recommended a judge give her full
custody which in turn allowed officials
to close the protection case and for
Eli's father to fight for custody in
family court on May 10th
they returned custody
and close the County case in Dakota
County
and 10 days later we got the new set
Helix was found dead while there are
still a lot of questions experts say
child protection cases take precedence
over any other kind of case in the state
from a divorce to a name change
Minnesota law says is that the juvenile
protection matter needs to go forward
and be resolved first before those other
types of cases that may involve the
child the goals too of the child
protection system are really different
than the goals of family court
also tonight I reached out to Dakota
County Social Services asking several
questions about Eli's case and a
spokesperson said due to privacy laws
quote we cannot comment further while
that Court Guardian with the state also
did not answer my questions only saying
our deepest sympathies go out to family
friends and all of our communities
impacted by this law so you know when
people do some [__] and then
afterwards be like our sympathies and
deepest condolences I just think part of
me is just like [__] you a six-year-old
is dead because you guys couldn't do a
proper job
our sympathies and condolences get the
[__] out of here
some of you might be watching be like oh
this is the issue you know we always
give custody to the mom or things like
that it's complicated
um fortunately the way the law is set up
over there it seems as though in order
for the debt to get full custody there's
a lot he has to go through and this is a
failing in the system more than it is
anything else is there a gender bias
involved maybe maybe it's just crazy to
think that somebody has known drug
problems no stable housing
mental health issues schizophrenia and
everyone's just like well I'm gonna give
this kid he's like what
the one time where you need child
protective services and all these
organizations to actually function and
do their goddamn job you find out
they don't do their job what did you say
the time that you need what
Child Protective Services who
child protective service
you had one child
what you have
in your name and
protect the child that's the name of
your [__] shout Protective Services
how broken the system is bro the child
is in
he's under a child protective order oh
because his living situation is unsafe
and untenable they're looking at them in
order for the parent who can provide
safety and well-being to the child to be
able to get full custody they have to
close the child protective order to send
the kid back to the dangerous
environment so that the person who can
protect them cannot file to actually get
you know how crazy that is
wait you know how crazy that is the more
you repeated the more you get pissed off
right this is like it's crazy isn't it
child protective the more I say it but
I'm like what you know what I keep
picturing look I keep picturing a kid on
the slide and he's just going wee and
like the chopper Texas and push him off
the slide and at the bottom there's just
Satan's mouth being like come on home
[__] yes that's pretty much that's the
darkness the first witness to take the
stand at trial Eli Hart's father Tory
Hart told the jury about the
six-year-old and the special daddy son
Bond they shared Tori testified quote
everyone loved him everybody knew who he
was at his Mound Elementary School he
detailed the genetic Health disorder
that had left Eli with flat feet and in
need of hearing aids what was otherwise
a normal energetic little guy who loved
fishing and wolfing down a giant plate
of Meatballs had his favorite pizza
joint quote he was everything to me
completed my life he just loves spending
time with me I love spending time with
him Tori Hart also acknowledged there
was an open and ongoing court custody
dispute realize mother Julissa Fowler
when Eli was killed Tori Wanted full
custody during the prosecution's opening
statement Brita Rapp told the jury of
eight men and seven women that thaler
killed the boy shooting him nine times
in close proximity with a 12-gauge
shotgun
I didn't want to say that detail but
yeah she grabbed a shot and blew him
open and the two in the trunk
it's actually really dark I I left that
detail out about me I guess they said it
so you know
installer you have a right to speak this
morning if you'd like you don't have any
obligation to speak but if you'd like to
choose to speak now is the time to do it
yes I would like to say something go
ahead
um I'm innocent [__] you all you're
garbage
thank you
that was shocking
that was shocking I did not expect that
[Applause]
hold up let me just listen she's gonna
get it let me listen let me listen
huh life in prison she has it yeah okay
yeah hold on listen
our lawyer's just like what
[Laughter]
[Music]
her old lawyer went
I don't think
let's go to the Deathstroke right here
I'm sorry I told you what
I would say is
she don't understand I told you what no
one else can
what okay as [__] up as this is this
is somebody
who appears to be schizophrenic
who's off their meds
but that's crazy mental health a lot of
things mental health broken system
that's what I think it is I don't think
it's a mental health problem I think
it's a broken system problem there's
plenty people with fine mental health
who end up doing bad things to their
kids I would have done the same
fair so if you had a proper system that
works in place it would have taken care
of the mental health thing fair so to me
it's a system issue there's always going
to be people with mental health issues
sure and if they don't have the help
that they need or if the system is in
place to protect the child from the
person with these mental health issues
that they're not treating themselves or
whatever it might be then it's a system
problem
that's a system problem the dad man
that's the time where you say stuff like
systemically these things are broken the
dad man [__]
so yeah yeah there's a tragic story but
I don't I just wanted to Showcase it
because I just thought it was so absurd
that a parent with so many reflects and
get custody of the child and it just
makes you think like
if this was a dad with these kinds of
issues do you honestly think they would
have got custody case close I don't know
I just kiss clothes right I mean your
dad's I know who've had to fight for
custody for the kids have to have such
good records the [__] that he had to get
full custody the [__] that they have to
prove
and I understand why there's a bias
towards the moms like I understand it to
some degree but when you see a case like
this with so many red flags the system
doesn't account for that part I don't
know that's just crazy to me that's
crazy
and the people working on Child Services
who let this kid go they're they're
complicit in this
you essentially took a kid put it into a
car with a drunk driver who's high off
everything possible and then watch them
burn and die and don't think like that
blood ain't on your hands
you know what let me take that back
maybe these people really want to fight
this order maybe systemically they just
didn't have the legal ability to do so
maybe for them this is heartbreaking as
well I have no idea
like you can't just hold the child in
your custody because you want to like if
the law says what it is they have to
follow that so maybe it's just that
[__] broken but it's just it's a
tragic thing and I think in these kinds
of moments you think of who you want to
blame but the end of the day I just
think as unsexy as his answer is this is
a systemic problem so
yeah that's pretty much well let us know
what you guys think in the comments
below we want to hear from you